what captain welcome to this video
playing dr. Lipton ago I'm not trying to
pronounce this in English dr. Lee Otago
it's a german player anyway and ok very
strange mix of a scandinavian and tongue
or sent a counter with the with the
modern let's see we are probably black
ones play Bishop g4 trying to get
pressure against divorce or h3 I thought
as a temple well spent how to set up
pieces say I probably let's try get the
center with c5 later which would be
seven months bd7 c5 something like that
but i always have d 50 came some problem
this is ok yeah but now the dark squared
bishop that's already the question to f4
to e3
okay that's um let's put it to a form
some seems a bit more active than I
expect yes night bd7 but if they play c
5 i'm going to play d5 and this is just
just not particularly great maybe e6 and
prepared c5 I don't know yeah it's
simply not on not a great position that
black hassium not it's not it's not
completely terrible but it's a bit
passive how to play this I could I could
try to exchange the bee gees having
bishop but it's not that great piece
actually okay one idea that he has this
may be c 5 d 5 e 6 m now with the rukon
yet so probably I should I should make
sure that it cannot do that c5 d5 d6
okay so it plays e6 first and he
prepares c5 now that I think of it night
b5 was an interesting rules before it's
even interesting now how does he even
protects his seven may I should have
played that one move the goal even I
mean it's still good but he could have
done something to prevent it now I
completely forgot about this and now I
can just grab here it's just just a pawn
gift and you still cannot place if I
ever cover of course because it's it's
96
yeah this is horrible what an a3 was
meant to prepare looks like Roxy 1 + B
form just improving pieces and advancing
on the queenside way I've got the pawn
and maybe Brooksie one was stupid could
have played before immediately okay but
it's not a not the end of the world just
me just kicking this away okay if I just
drop back I could take it's not not bad
but ok let's if I go back he could take
a 3 and d 4 ok so let's just take it so
I need to be a bit a bit cautious with
the time so this is a safe move pretty
preparing Queen d2 bush of age 6 on 22
immediately I could have taken f3 so I'm
just preparing to exchange his bishop on
g7 ok so he gives me the bishops for
this activity and I seem yeah well it's
not particularly dangerous ok i could if
i take out he got he gets deeper but i
get i get to take me six and this should
be enough oh i didn't expect that move
at that time doesn't look doesn't look
too great actually just just cover p2
I've got always get the ship d5 yeah
it's got 94 yeah maybe I could have
taken b6 but i'd like to improve control
over the position instead of grabbing
more pawns I mean if I if I just prevent
this counter play then i win anyway I
don't need any more pawns or any other
material I think f4 just wins a PCM
doesn't it
I hope at least not be three if i take
'if I've takes d2 takes f6 it takes be
one hmm ok but I thought Queen here what
would win the put win apiece as c 5 NB 3
is hanging
yes yeah he may he maybe he can maybe
set up a pen here hmm queen bee three
look III rookie three Queen a phone yeah
this is indeed possible that's bad luck
okay down one down 30 seconds this will
get get tricky with the time
gather position yourself is a rather
rather simple technical win but still
you you need to do it in 30 seconds
it's still the extra porn and check and
enter Bishop which is very strong here
on on d5
yeah but this is just just simple and
good trading the bishop for the night
just after I mentioned that the bishop
is better stranger bit to me hi my name
is just simple and and and didn't win
you can give check
check
10 seconds that's not much check check
check
okay interesting yeah check check
Oh Jeff for second source check check
check check check check check game drawn
ah yeah just just four or five moves but
yeah I'd spent far too much time at the
opening who know came so I'm a draw at
the end which really should have
happened but I don't ask me what I what
I did here just spending far too much
time I didn't play any warm-up games
this usually leads to even more
hair-raising time issues hmm then that
and it looked pretty decent so I wonder
if I should win a PCM okay computer says
I can just take yes why what can I take
i distract oh okay i didn't see that
just I was just stopping calculations
too early here after that I was thinking
okay I cannot take like this and it's
it's not good but I could just play here
and this is trapped and this is of
course I'm even better than the game he
has no moves to to save this and I can
do a sort of desperado but this is two
bishops and completely dominating
position completely out completely over
I mean just um just winning easily ok
this is also good for for a big
advantage but of course i thought i
would apiece but i had over
this idea this is in fact in fact not at
all good don't want don't want that like
gets this back with the pretty good
chances so this is better check getting
into them the end game it's a very good
end game many many ways to to maintain a
big edge i think i played this okay i
mean nothing nothing special it was just
winning all along but ok 19 seconds is
at least for me not not enough to to win
this ok thanks for watching